The HERC2 allele could affect the promoter of
OCA2 because the genes are so close together
or the allele could alter the HERC2 proteins
so that it interacts with OCA2 and directly
blocks its action. Now the other options are
not possible here because they change the coding
region on OCA2 but we know that the mutation is within the HERC2 gene which is
beside OCA2. So this is kind of a tough
question It's really putting together a lot of the knowledge
we talked about up to this point. About the
coding regions and non coding regions and possible interactions among
different proteins, as well as their locations on the
chromosome. If the two genes are beside each other. Then
alleles changing the coding region of OCA2 aren't really possible
because we're not saying they're overlapping. They're beside each other.
And so, the two options that are left are
that perhaps we know that non coding regions, the
regulatory regions of the OCA2 gene surround the gene.
They can even be thousands of base pairs away.
So mutation in the HERC2 gene. Could actually be
in one of the non coding regulatory regions of
OCA2, that reduces its transcription. And the other alternative
is that we actually change the HERC2 protein itself.
And the HERC2 protein physically interacts
with the OCA2 protein elsewhere in the
cell. And it inhibits or reduces its activity. Both of those are plausible.